I had a memorable time when sampled GSP
this is SM Entertainment in Seoul Korea
it was on March 27 2011 this year so
today I'm honored to be here at temple
with you and I feel very happy that our
to meet all of you here
a simple campus so also I'd like to
thank professor rubbishy and temple GSD
for this opportunity today I like to
talk about the rise of Korean Wave which
known as also as a hollow and SM
Entertainment globalization strategy
which led to a new Korean Wave question
Holly as a result of our great success
SM Entertainment's unique business
strategy has been benchmarked by
numerous companies worldwide and I'm
going to explain some of the key
components of this strategy by sharing
some of my passion today I hope I can
make this as exciting and memorable
experience for you and as it is for me
okay you're probably curious about you
know just always meant by Korean Wave
I'll let the video speak for itself but
first I'd like to introduce someone
while I was prepared preparing for this
speech for stemple GSB in Korea
especially and this speech in here so I
needed someone to deliver my thoughts in
English the network I talked to my son
let me introduce my son John
he will translate my speech into English
today as he did very well in Korea okay
my friend
okay let's take a look at the clip worth
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hyojong roll cut ya gotta keep my
panama's reticulum you're gonna soil
deposit Sumida what you have just seen
our scenes from Japan where Korean
culture has gone far beyond its typical
popularity and boundaries being
transformed into nothing less than a
social phenomenon so nice day how was
hanging on is gonna so good a Bahamas
assume American guy could come on on on
Kron communicator decimeters super
junior named jeongshik debuted on in
gonna happen in Hampton the door are not
welcome man you come young yet I'm gonna
get a scimitar at their debut concert in
Japan Girls Generation and shiny
attracted tens of thousands of fans a
remarkable feat Super Junior who never
officially debuted in Japan
drew 36,000 people at their arena tour
you can go Longhorns on rugged even
demons or children and a Halligan yato
another fashion how you can embody is
indeed a Sumida you've just witnessed
the creation of an unbelievable social
phenomenon called
the Korean Wave and now we call it the
new Korean Wave shin Holly Le Bon
permanently there hadn't do Chicago cop
okay and it doesn't end there let's take
a look at other cities in Asia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
young doe Shanghai Chengdu Nanjing home
contaminate IPC hilga Bangkok sleeping
in Manila Malizia wa milady CIA Kuala
Lumpur ego Singapore ESS Nina here were
the cities of Beijing Shanghai Qingdao
Nanjing and Hong Kong and these scenes
were from Taipei Bangkok Manila and
Kuala Lumpur each onion King of the ship
in London each onion Yi or a goat a SMS
veteran a child here Annan grant Ruby a
pop young yet cumin chicken is at home
grow in the communal Hammond's of toe
Holly ran internal documents of the
Sangha Nagasaki samhita sonicator Gondor
will only two Motagua Sumida in February
2000 SM Entertainment's group called
h.o.t first held her concert in Beijing
this was where the original Korean Wave
began a truly sensational moment which I
will never forget Korea University
London their achievement in Romanian ago
Hong Kong diamond Tegaderm diversity she
lit in Malaysia Singapore dome as she
attends yoga SME Bowden attitude Rhee
hegemony on the RIP activist Amiga 10
years after hods
first concert in Beijing SM
Entertainment artists have expanded
throughout Asia and are performing
large-scale concerts all over Asia
including Hong Kong Taiwan Thailand the
Philippines Malaysia the Singapore
Singapore and more Elrond reborn Luca
Chattanooga from what you've seen do you
get a tremendous ticket sense of the
tremendous moment
momentum of the Korean Wave is Akashi
Hallinan a she is a magnet anneandsandra
whoa okay Nakajima do do shi shi go roku
mr. medallion day he's an idol Alma
thought and take it all now the weights
meter then it sharp then it should come
as no surprise that what was once
considered a strictly
Asian phenomenon is now poised to spread
throughout the entire globe a dream only
by oneself is merely a dream however if
we all dream together
there's the beginning of a whole new
future for the global success of Korean
pop culture October 1997 lee sooman
xavier going to get shipped on and on a
I see a gentle Tom Segar comenzó tada so
tumble Amida cargo Europe quoi big one
economy forced legal culture next Yosef
Sumida kanji watch Watchmen conduit a go
cuckoo Damon on silencer Kakinada mbuna
da-da-da-da-da Sumida sonic language
epoch you see Janek are occasional
Arriba's in de castilla gangaji culture
forced economy in density also similar I
wrote the preceding quote 14 years ago
when I was launching in Asia in the past
Europe and America followed the idea of
economy first culture next as the
economies became stronger and as they
became world leading countries the
culture spread out and became known to
the rest of the world however I believe
that that could change what I set forth
was the idea of culture first economy
next buna Galeazzo communal to academic
community to honor and revere saw
communal mandan Narukami java to a
generic occasional high temperature Sega
kumquat on poun
we go Torchic approach singin artist
today will go cotillion Indian arrow
very catchy kumquat on to me Isabella
Ghanian Tony lo not can avoid similar I
believe that if the culture of a country
becomes known to form people first then
the economy of that country will would
thrive through those people the same
dream which I shared with their artist
fellow employees and staff members is no
longer just a dream now our dream has
finally become reality culture first
economy next OTA dangku me consider to
ethos kayo how did we get this far could
be you know this guy what was SM secret
to success
coupe American gap saw taiga Tanaka de
Aguirre over again heavy wish before I
talk about it I have a couple stories
that I want to share with you Amazon ago
Pillman Elton has Rami indefinite
achieve an indifferent Indianapolis
legendary battle tunisia zelenka's oh
yeah Pura Vida ah
model K chronica crimson you guys nikka
auto- system Carrington cuckoo non-jew
John Geoghan doing Vita ocarina Pandava
acraman a very young one Amari so good
challenge a motel a queer every single
Nevada education Bangka Wasaga
eigenvalue and entire crew swapped our
concrete and ganna die gigantic ax
handle you get er ah
Christian Toulouse and nimbala zolochiv
I promise buteo thanking me da okay
there was a man
all right there was a man that went to a
hospital and he was told that he had a
hypertension and that's a high blood
pressure for those of you who don't know
he asked the doctor what could have
caused this and the doctor said I mean
it could be one of many reasons maybe
you got from your parents so this man
told the doctor ah
I know it must have been from my wife's
parents and the doctor said no what are
you talking about you can't get it you
can't get it from your in-laws it's
impossible and the Martin and the man
told his doctor no you are wrong
try living with my wife okay I'll cover
that uncle moves me tell Monica hey guys
what's the problem can't place him
yoga you got all had a man in there we
got you tire tire give us a turkey I'm
jogging in general Titus he'll give us
on on a donkey garita la Vida Cougars on
top see Myung yi yo Jamal Iman's helping
me on pendulum de chine ei gives so
talking about women do you know what the
secret is to living a safe and sound
life as a man they say that you have to
listen to three women to live a good
life one is definitely your mother
second is definitely your wife so who's
the third is to lady in your car not
your wife not your wife she tells you
where to go and what to do in your
navigation ships system she's the third
woman the navigation lady don't get it
wrong
[Music]
tsegga non-governmental a seaman on
using good GPS data Iran ITA perineum
from drunk as haram direction about a
musical vangelia papanasam dodgy man you
don't technology none
kinga kinga a team inaudible man hands
hitter jumbo gentleman to Riga
haoyi are seen on technology that was
just a joke but the invention of GPS has
changed the way people live however it's
a technology that can be easily
understood
Donegal is cement CT than a neuronal
door welcome our symbiote MP meter probe
odometer see Tina Moonachie third Joe
Carter technology lynnium done I want to
unveil the secret through SM CT theory
CT as in culture technology Jana Jae
Hyuk shipped an engineer so he artists
wanna contented oh gotta go I see are at
home another shock instead I give up
your algorithm and annoy me da turn-on i
th e viado machine gun there who you
watching a diamond on a mossy th the
garage struggle purchasing a cake a
diamond in de culture technology I
coined this term about 14 years ago when
SM decided to launch its artists and
cultural content throughout Asia the age
of information technology had dominated
most of the 90s and I predicted that the
age of culture technology would come
next
the term CT is meant to distinguish
culture technology from information
technology SM Entertainment watch on
monitor technology Romita SM
Entertainment and I see culture as a
type of technology CP non-id Buddha
thoughts on yo hago could ego popped up
on technology media but culture
technology is much more exquisite and
complex than information technology
academic engagement iTunes heroine
Katrina lumion could solution currency
attempted in our damata handsome girl
John Doe remain checking our manual
routing as oh okay three knots picot
combined ESP none grandma's right in the
city narutimate Amiga whenever new
technology solution or system is
launched in the field of information
technology it can be explained through a
manual or a book within
three months however this is not the
case with culture technology SM
Entertainment on iPod on top of Japan
the c-pillar categories Aida SM
Entertainment is a company which
possesses much more complex culture
technology than information technology
in Tonga seat wah
hallelujah runa-san firmer stronger
Jeremy on Eden gaiety to illumine yondu
has a Hogan collaboration yunyoung way
happy alert one he Daniel Hamidah there
are three phrases phases of culture
technology the first phase of culture
technology is the export of cultural
contents the second phase of culture
technology is market expansion through
collaboration with local companies and
artists this will eventually integrate
Asia as one market one market force some
bengay CTO Hallinan Hyun Joo is optimism
and ergo gerondissa member gihan Google
City returns on Romita Crego closer to
me so and oh can you enjoy our endowment
create our children and bhaktir
bhagavaty race for Okinawa shmita
ecosystem gangee situa
SCMS aw she won on Holi a new plugin
book comida the third and last phase of
culture technology is to establish joint
ventures in each market and pass on
Korea's culture technology the ultimate
goal of the third phase and the Korean
Wave which has been attempted by SM is
to build a strong and reliable
globalized market and share the enormous
added value created
Eurobeat a community to do it the Sumida
we're gonna throw you a beauty Omega
Kojima and saw Kobe go get another game
another DJ a gun and saw promises hangar
angles Amparo hallelujah Sumida
initially Europe was dominating the
world culture
however as America's economy grew
stronger its cultural influence also
increased in Hollywood was established
to me on a hallucinogen super totems egg
a token illusion and ODM and radhika una
poca Sagami de asia
Prevot Tongo brennan tomato- sang in
Chengdu guitar Sam Taylor
some credo ami de papillons ambush plan
where's Asia's Hollywood or where will
the next Hollywood be created everyone
will agree that it is China our ultimate
goal is to accomplish the third phase of
culture technology in the biggest
emerging market in the world China let's
take a look at the following clips
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm so happy for this old world we are
put out to resent the most influential
Asian artists award and to excuse me
counsel Asian artists rest across
borders and baggage with their music
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but I didn't hear you talking Mindy draw
with all I mean here to my way
[Music]
h.o.t shivan indonesian dona h.o.t
rodrigo coil Sumida hungry have 300
sandwich intra go hungry and oppa
produce Audrey hanga ROA Han GUI builder
Graham K drama room and rotten day cozy
in Shangai Alameda in the first and
second clip you just saw h odn boa where
you just watched it is an example of
stage one of the Korean Wave Korean
singers have been penetrating into the
local market and Korean directors and
producers have been making Korean TV
series and movies with Korean actors a
chutiya can tawa though f4 a banister
none Han [ __ ] Ottoman ichigo's kakashi
hatake sauce hero new newsroom and and
Tapan JK Sumida and you go see borrow
edonkey highly regarded in the third
clip you saw counter from h.o.t and
Venice from f4 the two biggest stars in
Korea and Taiwan they collaborated and
formed a new duo come to Inverness it
was the first collaboration between two
major artists from different countries
and an example of stage 2 of the Korean
Wave maji maji by Shin Jung tae yong hwa
bucco near Anyang i'm double going
iguana hungry Paco tea dr. Hong Kong got
a new gear come dope watch is exactly
half chuckles Amanda no Aida the last
clip that we just saw is part of a movie
called the battle of wits this movie is
a collaboration among Korean actors and
producers and a director and producer
from Hong Kong and China respectively
how many la música let's move on to the
next clip
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Donna Deveney super junior-m Prevot epic
sein de chimie Chonga super junior-m
mirenkova che I do creme de super
junior-m sim1
vendor inner - tenemos una de super
junior-m a not hungry member monahan ago
to remember with member ingo me have
Auto Canada is a tarantula beginning
he'll dig up under Sudha super junior-m
on Han huachen googan rock Zambia
chatter Otunga Ponte mainland China -
Maduro hadn't grown pura vida super
junior-m is the hottest boy band in
China the M in Super Junior M stands for
Mandarin the members of this group
include both Koreans and Chinese members
show me the one you see the bottom left
is from China and Henry the one you see
on the bottom right is of Chinese
descent born and raised in Canada super
junior-m is the first group formed with
Korean and Chinese members performing in
mainland China as the main act quick
ohanga
chicken hungry thaw debut on ozone guru
bingo f @ swollen and flower extremities
in do what is a humble hockey audience
from the rear so a fellow came and Elvis
birthday
FX a nun hung Kuen member hogwash in
Gupta motor scene in Victoria Griego el
es durante New Guinean mboga plumb the
sanguine blonde chungu pass gesture I
can always see that another newly
launched girl group FX includes Korean
and Chinese members such as Victoria
from Qingdao China and amber also
Chinese who grew up in Los Angeles
FX has been very active not only in
Korea but also in other Asian markets
and as a side note if you type in f of X
into YouTube and you go into a our
channel our channel name is SM ent
for SM Entertainment you can see the new
music video of FX that was released just
yesterday so check it out yeah FX look
up how's it going to sing over like a
terminator it with you too
/ SM ent so you're channeling done
there's a Googler watch II have wind and
they're cuckoo youtuber to never turn
together you can put another window much
meda no time in that tunnel good-looking
member debandkeith imagery as I hang is
a toga we're on the new keyboardist or
can rock it in a circular pattern mama
so dumb dumb toka can help run on there
a bottom gig okay - new game in Hanzhong
gonna getcha getcha um de la turn on a
person emotion Johnny I think Otunga o
co DK oh yeah Johnny bide about
education with that oh I have another
story with so many foreign members in SM
I try my best to make them feel
comfortable you know they are so far
away from home so well the best way to
do that is to tell them some jokes to
lighten the mood you might appreciate
this one actually yeah I asked the
chinese-american who grew up in LA where
can UCLA at best at a glance he said
after a pause yeah that's a that's a
shiny thank you very much for promotion
oh grow okay okay anyways um so where
can UCLA best at a glance he said after
pause the best view of LA I don't know
San Gabriel Mountains and I said no that
is UCLA oh yeah yeah okay super junior-m
guac ofx una de jambe [ __ ] goombah lon
I said sententiously me sangha ninja
turcica de almeida
super junior-m and effects have already
gained tremendous popularity throughout
the whole Asian market and are ready to
take on the global market Iran at Easter
day years o Kadam in Paris from gangie
Helios am Charmander Enrico Sameera
chosen one token Hyun GI neo
huzzah huzzah huzzah leap an amoeba
these artists will eventually lead to
the third stage of the Korean Wave the
third and ultimate stage of the Korean
Wave is perfect localization
in and establishment of joint ventures
hang Wiggins hatten open man million
great we are ill banana stalks him too
man
king Ganon chips ham again in Grayson de
hann guca ill bone tumor again choose
eagles who you ago crew Kanan hop jockey
salamandra Timmy on medium a bhakti an
eagle legged and onion on Hangu gatina
rodriguez an uncomplicated lesson so as
you can see Korea has a population of 45
million Japan 130 million and China 1.3
billion if these three countries were to
hold an equal share of ownership in a
joint venture company the company will
make a huge profit and Korea would
undoubtedly become the wealthiest
country among the three because Korea's
population is the smallest ha ha t go
megachimp Iago knows her own team in
there boom yummy huh Mugen 3 what
azumanga jungle in row ko dongjun Timmy
my cotton ear Emerson crunchy me discuss
me de caca hang Papa L go meh angry so
as imagine goin on chinguga so Hanako
world vulnerable or party ah go to
Chicago to serotonin
- Timmy jaha pom on your team are
hunting me down on her own kickin ass
Allah is a good or a chungu kahan
without launching our agenda we are
currently preparing to launch two new
groups one will consist of seven Koreans
and the other will consist of five
Chinese members the interesting thing
about this is that the two groups will
have the same name now we are planning
to launch the group simultaneously in
Korea and China
singing the same song in two different
languages we plan to instigate this new
idea of two separate groups that will be
promoting as two parts of one bigger
group of twelve members this may may be
in niandra babu taiga Hindi Kannada
produce or Adina rockin Dickie lambda
grin kiss or todo a category nunca nunca
kisser
ali-a logic own a novo transversing
Olimpica a looser than 10,000 lambda
Chun Kuen at Estrada Stojko toe chungu
his Raiders face Sumida Chenango sun
aureus ms it roam and resent animals
the important thing is the emphasis on
made by not made in the main focus
should be directed toward who produced
the content and we will share and pass
on the technology it may be a Chinese
artist or Chinese company but what
matters in the end is the fact that was
made by our culture technology volunteer
Taha Lulu in hangeul mandra's in hong
kong tourism and raising hell you've
equipped oh boy albinism androgen inborn
you guys system in surah go boo in
Damian grant under wha gwaan go catch a
collaboration at one each our Halloween
October 12 and origin artists Sina
artist not Japan drone yojana to
Andromeda guru nanaka Duncan Barca to
dibiago in Nevada honkin star a mandolin
Vesnina of course cultural contents and
products of the first and second stage
of Korean of the Korean Wave will always
remain however we are preparing for the
next biggest market in the world and our
goal is to produce the biggest stars in
the world
Kumu Theresa Rebeck Tenten wanna go to
Eden Damien Amada hangeul ghee heaviest
ronan a penny grow in Sao chatter Oh
Tsugumi or nanorobotics Annika Sonam
Kruger Paraguay dr. Seaton Oprah wasn't
otaku Marie : in the end if this joint
venture is a great success and generates
enormous profits my hope is to see Korea
become the first country ever to become
a tax-free a tax-free country with the
huge profits generated from overseas
don't you think it's possible no really
and I will be the first one to dream
about it
yeah let's dream all together soon
Casimir Sandrine's from gangie CT WA
Hallie I run on children YouTube Twitter
Facebook Tumblr gotten new media social
networks obviously attend Jenga here on
new media what social networks officers
whom I saw go so go through to dojo
grows heroin and prosumer
producer/consumer Zamorin whenever
Teresita she grant rose Sumatran Jeong
RunAs oh she Honduran cupcake Hozuki de
voto goon bon Dorado to human emotion on
Coogan ken Jeong Moises arias me de
we are living in a time where more and
our prosumers connect new media and
social network services such as YouTube
Twitter and Facebook it was the
introduction of per Sumer a word
combining producer and consumer and new
media that the three phases of culture
technology and the Korean Wave were able
to spread and expand beyond borders
regardless of time and space young
fellah mobile scale let's take a look at
some more clips
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
honks horn audio Suika Kobe Bryant
addendum shoots on them done steps and
tires where you think the setting of
this video is for those of you who like
basketball this is the place where Kobe
makes his threes it's none other than
the Los Angeles Staples Center in the
United States Etonian quartz hi it I'm
going to do done at same town live we
turn Shin Young World War II in Elliott
and then together the scenes you've just
watched are from SMTOWN Live 2010 world
world tour in LA which took place on
September 4th
nineteen no not 19 2010 yeah ok last
year Sasha tell you to e communication
gap so talking Django cumin Romanian so
smitten Iran Kamini Yuga said ok cream
potato so Marcy suka in the video and
Callie when John mentioned it clear ago
automaton I was a big available to chat
chatter blue we go to chapter II turns
me on
nyan nyan top 10 a dragon and John
becomes ammonia so Sumida want Honda
lungs are on hunger get cheese progeny
Asia autonomy annuit an emoji Lucinda to
tell you the truth we had doubts prior
to the concert we weren't sure the
concert would sell out but the tickets
were sold were sold out completely and
the concert was such a great success
that ranked in the top 10 on America's
Billboard Magazine's box score concert
chart the more astonishing fact was that
more than 70 percent of the audience was
non-asian harinam Gombu scale let's see
some more videos
kirino's otaku Mahmood moderna lava
Yvonne Tony Moten eternal akuto Japanese
risotto kobayashi yumiko Aquila
Coco click you see Melanie Red Rooster
local cinema coca-cola nucleonic about
midday
you shouldn't appear to you that
recorded it yet so no Susana
[Music]
so say hgmd really cool you sociopathic
I say soon as me who Shinobu your
quickest answer then you idiot river
she's wrong side a cute little me man
can you tell you
[Music]
video sound ow stop could be stepping on
daisuki they're gonna Catania Tom
anymore
it does a GU stem so it's not what is
that see you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from sook Gong bangs on from Tahiti
visible than halfa million young harpazo
PR the first clip we just watched was a
report on the Korean Wave which was
broadcasted on a friend Fran a French
national television channel French to TV
in fact as a side note this year on June
10th we will be having an SM Town family
concert in Paris this is going to be the
first concert that we ever had in heaven
Europe
now you will be led to a co-op resn town
family consider a chair Kazumi de aquel
jeonghan Jehan into the Samhita torn pan
composite on go DK business Ronnie live
on Chico Vanya come JJ San Antonio de
Medeiros Nyanza ego-c Thomas Anthony de
Valentinois Hungary Mona's Anoka content
shinobi partake in some damage in two
minutes Miller you also saw Girls
Generation on the front cover of Nikkei
business Japan's leading business
magazine the cover title States this is
the next Samsung in Japanese which
clearly signifies the explosive growth
of Korea's culture industry and cultural
contents episode where certain biggest
epicenters a union in laguna ceja uri
non-comedogenic hometown ergo Eurobeat a
holiday on tamaak tum' buddha's rocket
engine on arrow
new media SNS pro to medullary nya
erosion coastal waters please endure the
amazing success at the Staples Center
the rise at the extraordinary social
phenomenon Korean Wave in Japan and the
ongoing spotlight received from Europe
have all been achievable through new
media social network services and the
rise of the pursue myrrh
my name be reacted on Qi Gong Gong Gong
Griego Chi Chi E Hagin media UNC video
Siravo Yagami de San Antonio Angolan
kuduro autocut Turin ana hajarajanaan de
granules otro Anthony Turin embassy
bodega jiangcuan e-reader Cosme de
futurists say that time space and
knowledge are the three most important
elements of the future I believe that
what's more important is how we can
completely transcend these elements this
is how the feature will be defined
yondu
equation Buddha Leonora God's hands are
so absurd on door Oh peaches Tomarken
forget on the degrees in de nowadays
knowledge and information are delivered
at the speed of light pepperoni a new
tool though social media service smart
phone smart TV domestic lamella she goal
torres Oh Tom Bogut on Delta go Q on the
with Mira through new media like YouTube
social media services smart phone smart
TV information is literally delivered
and exchanged by transcending time and
space Segen ERCOT acabo Crego in Gondo
door p.m. gaussian Bochy chicken coop in
Ghana Turin on Time Machine gotten grant
gendell infinitely it has been
encroached English Nina we have come to
an era where innovative ideas are on the
rise they transcend time and space like
a time machine not just by accelerating
time and expanding space Urantia can
become granite or an incremental human
on shegaon become one or two or none
Madrid how cooked Orozco viago those her
own content adrenaline flows from a
light that was with me at the center of
this trend transcending time and space
are pursue Murs
pursue Murs actively consumed these
transcending media and at the same time
produce new innovative contents
prose most elegantly Bundoora or quando
English patented and analyst Antonin
shin yongjae Rosa nada I believe the
base of the pursue mer age should be the
real name system shegaon become granite
or an important mistake as antimony
donation youngevity patent agent Damian
10-watt been John Guare content to the
law paul and monnel kilogram bid over
30,000 honda without a strong and
reliable real name system the spread of
false information and content will only
bring confusion and disorder in the
future in Europe China to Darwinian
authenticity nah so trabajo de roca
Managua shanira Samaritan Bolshevik
under a political one Enzo Tarkenton
borrow cumin and stir up your MonaVie
products in German support a stronger no
more Internet users who share knowledge
that without dying
no more Internet users who share
knowledge and information on the
Internet recklessly behind the wall of
anonymity we need to be
the feature with the rights of the
information or intellectual property
owners are protected a future where
accurate knowledge and useful
information is shared this conviction
must embody the prosumer zero pros
mistaken market hi hon John boa
contented parson on stream young diva
captain pop dr. dozous green tea party
media man Oh Dutch mahogany and Eglinton
boy upon you gay rodeo Kishida to Annie
goes on internet Sanjay's o haruka-chan
Jordan on her own she Jang Gyung hwacha
bungee mo de lodo
Python or C su casa milà accurate and
productive information sharing will only
be possible with the support of legal
and institutional backup such as a
real-name system this can also create a
brand new model integrating a new market
economy and capitalism with the Internet
Wikipedia door is at Hamilton John
border Auto key engine berapa Kusanagi a
tall woman Erica Mena even the website
Wikipedia's accuracy has been questioned
questioned and Wikipedia should also
come up with a plan or system to provide
more accurate and reliable information
and sources entertainment at an event on
synchronization or given Rohan MRP JIT
ERP Latin tongue tongue Dillingham young
eternal almost Honan human factor comes
on Tanith on weapon on the synchrony
generative and ranch Shinto King Kong
here oniy EJ Guadalajara traditional
business management approach such as MRP
JIT and ERP is not working well for the
entertainment industry I think we need
to develop a brand new and more
innovative management system based on
these synchronization reflecting human
factors emotions and creativity
so no Jim Cramer sentence can become
guanaco run on speed wa internet has on
young traveler returns her own teaching
Cory go pro Smotrich angle tomorrow
depending on dong goo ah synchronization
e onion peidong give a tea
synchronization on chickie Tyrone gunas
Hannibal paradigm and owner Cisco
tsunami de Rivoli Club paradigm HMA Toa
SM Entertainment rate Okinawa
with the principle of D synchronization
and creativity combined with all the
elements I've mentioned such as the
transcendence of time and space new
innovative knowledge delivered derived
from Internet and virtual reality and
the pursue Murs I believe that we can
create a new paradigm in the culture
industry and it is my dream that SM
Entertainment and I will be step
standing at the core of this new
paradigm Markham glad we're here on
Jamison outliers some going IKEA bargain
on Thunder didn't occur you go with an
NGO have you read the book outliers the
story of success by Malcolm Gladwell you
go boom boom dodge agates my pity Gates
Steve Jobs Peters Ruby wrote on oxygen
another eating ham today coach and a
drapey Gordon had Romanian lamb Darren
the audio gives me de those of you have
read the book already know this the
message it delivers is that the secret
of geniuses like Bill Gates Steve Jobs
and the Beatles all of whom play a big
part in shaping and changing history was
simply hard work a lot of blood sweat
and tears
sonica together yay Gannon Guru yoga
running water Sega 0 Yahoo scream EDA
grant nori ogre Sega Dean handsome
Tipton could ego your tongue run Marlowe
Pinos turn on grunts Hydra Tony and a
commander is in Dalton Amida and I want
to interpret the hard work expressed in
this book as three things interest
concentration and passion I believe that
these three elements will create a
genius Tony asymmetry going to Rogen
artists began hanging same chip Joon
young is he done Gator to me anything a
QQ a vertebra
okay yeah 100 I always remind the SM
Entertainment executives staff members
and artists to grab opportunities in
life through these three words interest
concentration and passion thyromine
Xena's he bona clingy Gondar and Maurice
Mira so he goes in wooden ceramic atop
catches hit when I hear go wooden died
getting a junkie all
Borden's around reggae finding Joe
Borowski Benecke ago in Dhahran Mario
wasn't harmed there's a saying that you
only get three chances in life the way I
see it is I don't think this means that
everyone gets exactly three chances in
life but that on average people get
three chances in life to ping me I'm
doing a 100-megaton
between a keg and ambien lhamo jacuzzi
come young Aaron hambone Aikido ananda
asmita Tongan doors even on one panel
John Allegro creo way authentic Johnson
a mega man Tiago go those who wanna get
a pyro genin could you need should be
honest I'm a giver Sameera in other
words this means that out of 100 people
one person may get three hundred chances
while the rest of the people may get
none you may think that life is so
unfair why do I do these opportunities
only come to certain people why do some
people succeed while others don't
the fact is opportunities go to those
who make persistent strides to improve
themselves
you join a gym beyond 100 no don't
ramble creo Sandra Oh Tony Paniagua que
digo Crego an easy meerkat indeed a tip
to nagisa Canada crooked em en todo lo
que tipo your tongue is hanging on go
Sumida yo John Pennington game the
checker children were tiny ball who your
tongue apparel is hara mirch in the
roman delusion for these people are
these people they are the ones to
concentrate on what interests them and
naturally develop passion from then on
that passion is what makes a genius who
your target in sahaja yoga University o
Kyoji an important errand run Hanna's
humanist auto-ship - ha ha ha numero
nazo your tongue is high energy I'm
kiddin me de Lesseps integrity team
Otago
Barroso Kyogre oh gee I'm kiddin
bismillah chances will be created and
will come to the geniuses who have
acquired that passion those who do not
get as many or any chances are the ones
who have interests but do not
concentrate and consequently don't
develop that passion
therefore they will never become
geniuses and as a result won't be able
to open the windows of opportunities
Yogi's in Mandarin Boulder CO and yo-yo
ma is a category in Bandidos a nom de
kere padded rich we got here in and from
the Delta Omega Omega I know and I
believe all of you here have passion and
all of you here are ready to embrace the
opportunities that befall you
congratulations episode Madison today to
see achievements Gong Gong Gong watch
ecbert or announced arrow social
networks observer wrote an immediate
antenna Windham Cranston de Jouy a
semi-auto can be raised
current social networks avoir Tyrone
video H yoga dirty scale once again we
are at a point in human history where we
can transcend time space and knowledge
with new social network services and
innovative media among the newly created
social network services and media will
SM Entertainment and I believe able to
lead the way
cousin guzar VSOs team Erica Jong Hyun
oh-seok CEO you can borrow an artist or
go to own luma grahamandrach m de gue
certain has her own social network
service wha her own video a pattern
change Giada push me on chicken become
guanaco run-ins here on Sigma del dome
and our analysis Cocinita well in order
to achieve this goal
the most important thing for SMS to
create and produce good music and good
artists and through the good content we
create not only will they contribute to
the speeding up of the development of
new media but will also be able to
create an unprecedented business model
that transcends time and space my
Moroccan guy team are similar to the go
on yet another one there's one last
point I'd like to make before wrapping
things up Arobin Jerome did ichigo-san
take a gonna leader santa card de dos
he's an R&D so Junction you are getting
Kikaider
toss a nut hidden on [ __ ] watch
Anika Stanford students what are the
most important considerations to make
when deciding on a career or finding
your life path goes on some wanna in
general Vo turn on the oven de catalunya
chin beyond your own machinee
kudo amp a one-run gg-good 2000 CC group
choreography in non-irritant economics
media i would say to live a successful
life choose a career path where you can
put your knowledge to practical use Pro
tomahawk sí sí seguro si leaders hunter
kannababu de oxytocin young oh don t
meet Damian humble Kyle if so it would
be more important than choosing a career
based on your knowledge
cousin organization is hunter can kooler
- I Anton goyda chim cocoon 2000 Santa
Catarina sig / Cassini Chihuahua anta
Ron aluminum unit on Damian
kamichan passage one another as its
diameter but even more importantly
choose something that you like to do
that's simple
I'm sure many of you have chosen a
career that suits your major or your
field of study
but have you ever asked yourself if you
actually liked or loved your job if not
you should start the search again right
now without hesitation LA Dodgers come
the women have done Tommy Lasorda and
Waldo see the jewels in cheek where
Tongo Tongo AP government granted a
Bowdoin goes on Tizen EOD job Macedon
you Peggy
Peck top Anita okay I guess meda who you
pick any localized degree on Cuban Jones
foga potent we're Amanda how many males
who do good on their we do you might
have already heard this but after the
Dodgers won the World Series
they asked head coach Tommy Lasorda for
a secret to success he said he got from
a milk carton
they drank when he was young the milk
carton said happy happier cows make
better milk
well if cows need to be happy in order
to be better producers then what does
that say about us humans
crota men in general some gongyo grow
yet he'll give you a taco Jeanette
cheesy girl gajigo eaters hunter Cabo
Tokyo taiga twogo chromosome Guangzhou
Internet has email kokujin she Omar
Khayyam TMP Gary Tom Yum Goong wall kayo
then finally what is the most important
secret to living the most successful
life rather than choosing a job with
your knowledge and merely doing the job
that you like what would be the best way
to a successful life goes on to include
a laundry trigger and an emoji media you
should naturally enjoy the job that you
choose to go Bianco to you and Tammy on
your journeys hang energy and request
Amira your tongue of simeon clear it is
all directors so obseunikka if you're
not feeling happy with what you do and
not enjoying what you do you will not be
able to bring out the passion inside you
and no genius in that field will never
will ever come out of a life without
passion I prefer this in English I don't
want my son to talk about it this is
very possible
this may be hard to believe now but I
used to be a very very popular singer
really adored by you know many young
female fans in fact there was some
teenage girls who said they would even
run away from home if I got married
finally I got married nobody ran away
from home
but these days my wife loves me most
when I catch a bad cold
she says it's easier to love me when I
have to wear masks covering my face
wearing sunglasses only on my pants but
you know anyway I'm happier now more
than ever so because you know I know I'm
much more passionate and happy when
producing great music and artists turn
chingadera to an artist wah uma Thurman
Dara Singh decree go go solo Minaj chuga
chuga came and reported on over to go
poor no more keep on Neda from day one
I've produced great artists and great
music that I love I really love what I
do and I will continue to love every
minute of it Arobin chew gum gum gum
brush location done
Corrigan Busan leader has your singer
listen to you Chico Messina neither
animal approach how do I think I can
either Chihuahua in nyle
could you go around Earth trigger to
biggity oh it's [ __ ] what are you
currently studying what career path are
you planning to take do you love what
you do or what you plan to do are you
ready to enjoy Anita why is he going to
go jinenji
to go show Tommy on your ohmmeter
entertainment to tell Bruce show then
did you enjoy your time with me today if
you did how about starting a career in
the entertainment business
let's join FM and the Tama
thank you very much